axé sur la méditation et la recherche de
la paix intérieure aux yeux des
Occidentaux le bouddhisme tibétain
apparaît souvent comme une religion
au-dessus de tout soupçon la réalité
s'avère pourtant parfois tout autre
comme vient de le démontrer à l'instant
ce documentaire cette enquête réalisée
par Elodie Emery et vendrille Lanos
viole emprises mentale détournement de
fonds n'épargne pas cette religion nous
allons en débattre maintenant avec nos
invités présents sur ce plateau de débat
doc et l'Audi Emery est avec nous
bienvenue c'est donc vous qui avez mené
cette enquête aux côtés de notre
confrère vendrille Lanos en quête dont
vous avez par ailleurs tiré un livre un
du même titre que votre documentaire que
nous venons de voir à l'instant
bouddhisme la loi du silence publiée
chez Jean-Claude latesse on va voir avec
vous bien sûr après votre film votre
votre enquête en quoi
ce sujet qui nous préoccupe aujourd'hui
constitue une loi du silence Anthony
Bousmar est également avec nous
bienvenue vous êtes le coprésident de
l'Union bouddhiste de France l'UBF
depuis
2021 et enseignant à l'Institut
catholique de Paris on va rappeler que
l'UBF et l'interlocuteur des pouvoirs
publics sur toutes les questions
touchant au bouddhisme dans notre pays
le bouddhisme en France c'est la
quatrième religion en nombre de
pratiquants il y a combien d'adeptes du
bouddhisme en France alors vous avez
utilisé deux termes pratiquants et
adaptés en termes de pratiquants en
règle générale on avance les chiffres de
entre 600 000 et 1 million pratiquant en
termes d'adeptes plus sympathisants on
va dire et là c'est pas l'UBF qui est
avant ce chiffre c'est Frédéric Lenoir
il avance 5 millions ça couvre un
spectre très large de celui qui va
lire un ouvrage de temps en temps à
celui qui va vraiment s'intéresser à
approfondir sa connaissance et
sans forcément passer le
et devenir lui-même bouddhiste c'est
aussi le cette religion et la sixième en
nombre de lieux de culte combien de
lieux de culte concernant le bouddhisme
en France à peu près on en compte à peu
près 400 du petit centre vraiment à la
structure beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
vaste
et l'UBF regroupe à peu près 80% d'entre
elles pour voir tout de même rappeler
que l'origine bouddhiste se situe en
Inde et que seulement 1,4 % des
bouddhistes vivent ailleurs que dans les
pays asiatiques le bouddhisme c'est tout
de même 600 millions d'adeptes dans le
monde
et pour ce qui est de l'Europe on trouve
les bouddhistes surtout en France en
Allemagne et en Grande-Bretagne c'est
aux États-Unis qu'on trouve le plus de
bouddhistes en dehors de l'Asie avec en
vision environ 2 millions d'adeptes et
puis enfin raphaël Liogier est avec nous
bienvenue vous êtes vous-même bouddhiste
philosophes sociologues des religions
enseignants à Sciences Po
Aix-en-Provence et au Collège
international de philosophie à Paris et
votre dernier livre que qui va paraître
dans les mois prochains apparition est
prévu pour la fin du mois d'août je
crois s'intitule chaos chaos ça veut
dire KO en français site internet grec
bien sûr ko
la promesse trahie de la modernité c'est
un ouvrage qui est publié aux éditions
les liens qui libèrent je me tourne tout
de suite vers vous pour peut-être
actualiser tout de suite le documentaire
que nous venons de voir concernant
l'affaire Robert Sparte qui a été jugé à
Liège on l'a bien vu dans votre film
donc il a été condamné en appel en 2020
à 5 ans de prison avec sursis notamment
pour emprise violence et abus sexuel sur
mineur il s'était pourvu en cassation le
jugement cassation a-t-il été rendu et
ce jugement en appel a-t-il été confirmé
oui absolument le la cassation confirmé
la condamnation à 5 ans de prison avec
sursis et à des dommagements financés
pour les victimes Robert Sparte est
toujours en Espagne comme vous le dites
dans ce documentaire à notre
connaissance robespace vit toujours en
Espagne et il fait maintenant l'objet
d'une enquête en France puisque là
l'enquête est le procès qu'on a suivi ce
sont déroulés en Belgique et maintenant
il y a une enquête qui a été ouverte
dans le sud de la France puisque le
centre qu'on évoque dans le film se
situe près de Castellane dans le sud de
la France et donc les victimes ont
décidé d'engager une procédure
maintenant en France donc avoir si
l'enquête donne des résultats et si si
Robert speed c'est comme d'une nouvelle
condamnation puisque on peut considérer
que cinq ans avec sursis pour les faits
qui lui était reproché c'est peut-être
léger même s'il y avait prescription
32 victimes étaient allées vers vous au
moment de votre enquête vous avez donc
identifié 32 victimes soit de violences
sexuelles
violences psychique et vous dites la
plupart du temps ces abus sont commis au
nom de la religion elle-même oui
expliquez-nous en fait le donc déjà les
32 victimes qui nous ont parlé il s'agit
pour toutes de victimes de violences
sexuelles
on a eu vent d'autres victimes qui qui
ont été soit
sous emprise soit qui ont été témoins de
violences sexuelles là les le chiffre de
32 qu'on avance c'est vraiment des gens
qui eux-mêmes ont été victimes au nom de
la religion parce que en fait le motif
qui est avancé pour la relation sexuelle
c'est le fait que un contact avancé avec
le maître en contact physique avec le
maître
permet un accès plus rapide et plus
pays plus immédiat à l'éveil donc
l'éveil c'est cette notion que les
Occidentaux ont peut-être confondu avec
le bonheur
c'est une hypothèse en tout cas et qui
pourrait se comparer à la grâce dans la
tradition chrétienne et qui est cette
libération de toute forme de souffrance
à laquelle vraiment aspire les
Occidentaux qui se lancent dans le dans
une quête bouddhiste et donc les maîtres
dont on parle on très souvent avancé
l'argument que le le contact physique
rapproché le fait vraiment d'avoir une
relation qui dépasse parfois le cadre
conventionnel est un accélérateur
d'accès à l'éveil j'ai appris en
travaillant ce dossier à la suite de
votre enquête qui a un principe
doctrinal dans le bouddhisme il y a
interdiction de dire du mal de ses
maîtres et de ceux avec qui on a partagé
l'enseignement d'un même maître vous
confirmez que c'est une doctrine
fondamentale interdiction de dire du mal
de tout être vivant c'est à dire veut
des maîtres ou pas des maîtres c'est pas
que c'est pas quelque chose qui est
spécifique qui est spécifique au maître
mais il est vrai que dans le levage
Ryana et dans le tantrisme en général il
y a une relation particulière avec le
maître le goût qui est vraiment le
gourou pour une raison simple c'est que
c'est supposé être la voie la plus
rapide la voix la plus presque immédiate
c'est la voix de la transformation et
comme c'est une voix qui est plus rapide
elle est plus vertigineuse comme elle
est plus vertigineuse si on tombe en
quelque sorte bien c'est ça fait plus
mal dont d'où l'abandon à la vision du
maître une partie de ce qui a été oublié
par les occidentaux y compris par
exemple par les disciples de ce gars une
potier je pense qui est vraiment en
cause la fortement
en 2019 qui est fortement en cause dans
le film qu'on vient de texte les textes
bouddhistes tibétains en particulier si
je puis dire sont conscients de cette
difficulté c'est pour ça qu'il y a des
des
énormément de textes sur comment choisir
un mètre parce qu'une fois qu'on l'a
choisi effectivement il y a un rapport
il y a un abandon tel que là ça risque
d'être dangereux si ce n'est pas entre
guillemets un vrai maître autrement dit
il y a des textes qui vous expliquent
quels sont les caractéristiques
extérieures que je ne peux pas connaître
moi en tant que disciple par définition
parce que je suis pas éveillé or ça sont
des textes qui sont quasiment passés
sous silence par les disciples
occidentaux parce que ça serait une
manière de dire ah bah oui si je
comporte comme ça à la base c'est que
c'est pas vraiment un maître digne de
fois il paye difficile pour des victimes
de prendre la parole de dénoncer
c'est fait violence dont elles ont été
les victimes avec une doctrine comme
celle-ci c'est à dire qu'on doit une
obéissance absolue à son maître alors
les textes tibétains ont été très loin
dans la description de ce que devait
être un maître authentique mais aussi un
disciple authentique mais si on remonte
aux origines c'est à dire au Bouddha
chacun mon lit lui-même il a toujours
dit dans ces enseignements à ces
auditeurs ne prenez pas pour argent
comptant si on transpose d'un langage
d'aujourd'hui ce que je dis et ne mettez
pas en pratique ce que je dis par
respect pour qui je suis ou pour les
qualités que vous me prêtez mais étudier
et prouver et si au terme de cette étude
vous en arrivez à la conclusion que oui
ce que je dis fait sens à ce moment-là
mettez en pratique donc pour reprendre
votre question non il n'y a pas une
demande d'une confiance aveugle au
contraire elle doit être étayée d'où la
nécessité de pouvoir
prendre le temps de pouvoir de devoir
même prendre le temps d'étudier celui
auprès de qui on veut on veut étudier
dans le cas qui nous occupe pour ces
enfants de aucaze ce sont des enfants
qui ont été laissés dans ce sens par
leurs parents
les enfants
qu'est-ce qu'ils peuvent dire
c'est ça la difficulté ils sont pas
nécessairement en âge de pouvoir
formuler un avis étayé et
ça a donné vraiment à une pratique
de façon complètement libre alors le
problème c'est que évidemment c'est
terrible quand les victimes sont des
enfants mais c'est aussi terrible quand
les victimes sont des adultes et que les
disciples sont soumis à des injonctions
contradictoires parce qu'à la fois le
fait effectivement de devoir observer
son maître pour déceler en lui les
qualités d'un maître authentique et d'un
autre côté il y a aussi le la
l'immense foi que les gens ont par
exemple la personne du dalaï-lama ou des
individus comme ça qui représentent le
bouddhisme et qui ont tous adoubé les
mettre dont on parle donc adouber
robespace adoubet Sogal rincoche c'est
un peu compliqué de dire aux gens c'est
une façon en fait de faire peser la
responsabilité de la dénonciation et
même de la de la détection de
l'authenticité d'un maître sur les seuls
disciples puisque le Dalai à lui-même
qui avait connaissance de ses faits a
inauguré le centre de ce galeries
potchet en 2008 en grande pompe donc ça
veut dire qu'on suppose que les
disciples bien que le centre soit adoubé
par le maître spirituel le plus connu et
le plus respecté du bouddhisme tibétain
il va falloir quand même qui se méfie de
la personne donc c'est c'est on dit que
le flacon est trompeur il est d'autant
plus trompeur que que l'étiquette est
signée par le dalaï-lama en personne
donc
le Conseil suivant quand on n'est pas
content de son maître on s'éloigne sans
faire de bruit ça on a retrouvé la trace
d'un échange de mails entre un disciple
qui donc informé le bureau du dalaï-lama
d'agissement qui lui avait paru
extrêmement choquant et il a reçu ce
mail qui lui disait de s'éloigner sans
faire de bruit il y a une pression très
forte là dessus de ne pas justement au
nom de ne pas dire du mal de de voilà de
pas faire de vagues et du coup le le
système est organisé de sorte que en
réalité la reproduction des affaires
peut continuer à l'infini il y a rien
pour l'arrêter au-delà de de la question
de ne pas dire de mal je crois que ce
qui est ce qui a été mal pas ne pas
dénoncer les violences sexuelles
s'abstenir de dire qui peut être
considéré comme du mal y compris
lorsqu'il y a violences sexuelles oui
bien entendu bien entendu c'est un
délicieux non-assistance à personne en
danger par ailleurs mais voilà mais ce
que je voulais dire c'est que ça a
touché essentiellement le bouddhisme et
des groupes tantriques un truc à dire
pourquoi parce que dans le bouddhisme il
y a plusieurs types de véhicules un
groupe d’entriques c'est quoi justement
c'est un véhicule particulier que
j'allais y venir pour être plus
pédagogique c'est que on a des véhicules
différents c'est à dire des véhicules on
dit bon il faut respecter les règles
morales façon détaillée s'abstenir
d'avoir une une sexuels qui serait trop
anarchique vous faites fidèle si on
décide de se marier etc etc puis il y a
des groupes et puis peut-être il y a le
véhicule de la compassion où là c'est
l'accent qui est mis sur l'amour et puis
il y a le véhicule tantrique où on
considère que tout est en illusion dès
le départ c'est ce qu'on considère toute
façon dans le bouddhisme dans la
première phrase du damapada qui est le
texte central du bouddhisme dit en gros
tout est mental bon mais le dernier
véhicule le véhicule qui est supposé
être le véhicule supérieur c'est celui
qui dit en gros même les règles morales
même les règles d'abstention sexuelle
finalement sont une illusion et donc par
conséquent le comportement du maître qui
peut avoir l'air d'être un comportement
non conventionnel
et bien nous ne sommes pas tous chapitre
de juger ne sont pas susceptifs de le
juger et ça ça cette généalogie cette
façon de se comporter qu'on appelle la
folle sagesse c'est quelque chose qui a
quand même été exploité déjà depuis les
années 70 avec un individu qui est
Shogun trompe pas qui a diffusé ça et
donc ça a été c'est un exemple qui a été
suivi aussi en Occident cette histoire
de fold sagesse je voudrais rebondir sur
le terme système
c'est de féliciter de ce documentaire
vous l'avez dit dans la presse et en
revanche et je vous le renier ce terme
système et cette idée que peut-être
systémique je remercie et je vous
remercie
en face à face madame pour avoir produit
ce documentaire puisque indéniablement
il y a eu des horreurs de commise et il
fallait les dénoncer et ce que vous avez
offert aux victimes c'était d'un campus
exprimé leur douleur et en ça
je dis un grand bravo là où je suis
beaucoup plus sur la réserve c'est dans
la dénonciation d'un supposé système là
je trouve que on bascule dans du
complotisme ou finalement on a
l'impression vous donner l'impression
que le bouddhisme au sens général
puisque là le titre du documentaire et
de vous trouvera chez le bouddhisme la
loi du silence c'est pas le bouddhisme
tibétain c'est le bouddhisme la loi du
silence donc c'est donner l'image
l'impression que c'est tout le
bouddhisme qui est qui essaie d'étouffer
quelques affaires que ce soit et ça en
ça c'est en train de nous dire que on
est face à des cas isolés d'ailleurs qui
sont un peu anciens alors c'est ça que
vous êtes en train de nous dire je suis
en train de dire effectivement que fort
heureusement ce sont des carrières
anciens
malheureusement
qui n'ont pas obtenu qui n'ont pas eu
l'écho qu'il nécessitait pas le fait des
institutions c'est juste le fait de la
justice et
[Musique]
les centres bouddhistes sont ni pires ni
meilleur que que n'importe quel
organisation humaine ça reste des êtres
humains représentés dans un espace
délimité donc là vous n'êtes pas
d'accord évidemment vous vous dites
c'est un système je répète le mot je le
revendique pour au moins de raison c'est
que déjà par le nombre d'affaires en
fait il s'agit pas de cas isolés mais de
cas qui se sont reproduits vraiment à
chaque fois selon un modèle un peu
similaire donc déjà il y a la répétition
du du nombre d'affaires d'une part et
d'autre part il y a le silence des
institutions et quand l'institution
reste à ce point un silencieuse en fait
quand on a connaissance d'agissement
aussi grave si on ne les dénonce pas
publiquement on les couvre c'est aussi
simple que ça et ce ne sont pas des
faits anciens ce il y a beaucoup
d'affaires qui sont récentes il y a des
le dernier Lama qu'on interview qui dont
les centres principaux sont en Espagne
et en Suisse continue d'enseigner sans
être inquiété le moins du monde il y en
a d'autres qui sont qui sont encore en
train d'enseigner tous les jours et la
raison pour laquelle c'est nous des
journalistes qui qui libérons cette
parole c'est parce que tous les autres
recours et tout ce qu'ils ont essayé
avant à échouer le journalisme en fait
c'est le dernier recours donc je
maintiens le mot de système bon je
dirais que le mot système c'est on peut
l'utiliser ou pas l'utiliser mais c'est
peut-être pas forcément le bon mot
c'est-à-dire qui est quelque chose de
systémique moi je j'aurais tendance à
être d'accord avec Elodie en revanche je
dirais que ce n'est pas systématique
systémique mais c'est pas systématique
et le deuxième point c'est qu'il y a pas
d'intentionnalité générale parce qu'on
dit c'est à dire que la théorie du
complot ça suppose qu'il y aurait une
intentionnalité cachée il y a pas
d'intentionnalité cachée en revanche il
y a une abstention c'est à dire il y a
une absorption et cette abstention elle
est liée à quelque chose justement de
spécifique aussi c'est porté par une
certaine interprétation de la doctrine
on avait parlé lorsqu'on avait discuté
ensemble de doctrine justement dans la
version tantrique autrement dit j'y
reviens c'est très important parce que
ça avait commencé dans les années 70-80
sur cette idée que il y aurait un niveau
dans le bouddhisme ou le mettre peut se
comporter de façon complètement non
conventionnelle c'est-à-dire que même
devant les disciples il peut avoir des
relations sexuelles faire des choses
complètement il peut se saouler il peut
être parce que de toute façon lui il est
hors des conventions il est au-delà de
l'illusion s'il est au-delà de
l'illusion nous nous ne sommes pas
susceptibles de le juger et ça c'est
problématique parce que c'est structurel
là pour le coup dans la dans la doctrine
elle-même dans son interprétation et
deuxièmement l'autre élément c'est que
le bouddhisme c'est une religiosité ça
fait partie qui a été en partie
reconstituée à travers les valeurs
occidentales autrement dit il est on va
lui dire presque par nature depuis les
années 80 immunisé contre la critique et
tout en étant extrêmement désirable
parce qu'il correspond aux logiques de
développement personnel etc autrement
dit il y a un plus grand nombre de
victimes potentielles donc c'est plus
facile pour les gourous potentiels qui
sont humains comme on l'a dit comme tout
le monde et qui donc vont glisser parce
qu'ils ont la facilité du point de vue
de l'évolution de notre culture et la
facilité du point de vue de la doctrine
alors il y a une autre un autre
personnage qui est mis en cause dans ce
documentaire c'est maturité qui
l'interprète en réalité officielle du
dalaï-lama l'interprète français si on a
bien compris il ne porte parole de rien
concernant le bouddhisme c'est lui qui
le dit vous l'avez mis en cause dans ce
documentaire pour son silence justement
et il vous a répondu il a cherché à se
justifier d'une certaine manière dans
l'Obs avec une très longue interview
publiée le 15 septembre 2022 avec une
forme de mea culpa tout de même voilà ce
qu'il dit je réalise que les victimes
attendaient de moi un soutien public
plus retentissant et une condamnation
plus vigoureuse de ses crimes que je ne
l'ai fait depuis 2017 dans plusieurs
émissions ou blog je le regrette
profondément pour le reste il récuse vos
accusations mais il accepte finalement
le blâme voilà ce qu'il dit il dit autre
chose d'intéressant qui peut peut-être
fournir une clé de compréhension il dit
voilà au Tibet le bouddhisme tibétain
comporte 4 grandes écoles indépendantes
des unes des autres les monastères les
cendres sont gérés de façon autonome il
n'existe aucune institution de contrôle
autrement dit il y a une autorité
spirituelle d'ailleurs mais il y a pas
d'autorité institutionnelle dans votre
religion ça c'est peut-être un des
problèmes autorité spirituelle des par
exemple c'est pas l'autorité spirituelle
du groupe auquel appartient à Matthieu
Ricard le Hugo qu'elle appartient
Matthieu Ricard c'est l'énigbapa le
dalaï-lama il est gay look il se trouve
qu'il est autorité spirituelle des
gélouks c'est à dire d'une certaine
école des bouddhisme tibétain en même
temps il est autorité politique pour des
raisons historiques sur le le Tibet et
donc l'ensemble des bouddhistes
tibétains mais c'est pas c'est pas un
pape si vous voulez ça fonctionne pas
exactement de la même manière donc juste
quand même c'est bien de le de je répète
néanmoins les monastères et les centres
sont gérés de façon autonome il existe
aucune institution de contrôle parce que
c'est pas là un des problèmes auxquels
on touche aussi avec cette enquête c'est
un des problèmes mais aussi un des
mérites du bouddhisme c'est une grande
liberté un centre se constitue à partir
du moment où un certain nombre de
personnes décident de se réunir pour
étudier le bouddhisme tibétain il crée
une association et c'est tout
effectivement le aujourd'hui la
personnalité du dalaï-lama ça renommée
le fait qu'il soit prix Nobel de la Paix
etc fait que il est autorité morale
reconnue par tout le monde mais
alors au Tibet déjà c'est un c'est un
chef politique
les quatre écoles du bouddhisme tibétain
ont chacun chacune leur propre chef
c'est elle qui ont
disons un pouvoir
relatif sur leur lignée sur les les
responsables qui occupent les différents
postes le dalaï-lama n'a absolument
aucun pouvoir sur c'est un petit peu le
chénon le lien entre toutes les toutes
les écoles et surtout le peuple tibétain
alors je reviens à cette fameuse
interview de Matthieu Ricard quelle
leçon tirez-vous de cette histoire voilà
la question qui lui est posée dans cette
interview accordée à l'hôte et voici sa
réponse il me semble indispensable
qu'une structure représentative comme
l'Union bouddhiste de France puisse se
charger de cette responsabilité et
servir de garde-fou à de futurs déviance
alors évidemment la question qu'on se
pose c'est de savoir qu'avez-vous mis en
place pour mettre en garde sur de futurs
déviances alors au sein de l'ubué de
France est une structure relativement
récente puisqu'elle a été fondée en 86
elle est encore en phase de
développement d'accroissement
pour l'instant le le nouveau disque de
France fonctionne sur le bénévolat
exclusivement donc avec ses forces et
ses faiblesses
j'apprécie et j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour Matthieu Ricard la patate chaude
qui nous a renvoyé nous met une certaine
pression
ce n'est pas en l'état actuel le rôle de
l'Union boutique de France le rôle de
France vous le disiez en introduction
c'est de servir d'interlocuteurs au
pouvoir public nous sommes la courroie
de transmission entre les pouvoirs
publics et les centres bouddhistes les
bouddhistes et les pouvoirs publics on a
aucune
aucun pouvoir administratif politique
doctrinal sur les centres alors dans la
croix néanmoins quotidien La Croix nous
sommes le 14 septembre 2022 vous saluez
le travail salutaire de l'enquête de nos
confrères et vous indiquez que la
Commission éthique de l'UBF poursuivre
son travail de prévention de telles
dérives lors d'une journée juridique
prévue en novembre
pour
en matière de prévention alors la
commission éthique se réunit a se réunit
encore hier soir oui et donc
déjà c'était de de rappeler un certain
nombre de choses qui relève du bon sens
de ce qui peut et ce qui peut pas être
fait au sein de centre bouddhiste et
notamment dès qu'il y a une hiérarchie
enseignant
disciple il y a des choses qui relèvent
du bon sens
de tout à l'heure autre chose dites-vous
et notamment les relations sexuelles
non a priori ils sont complètement à
proscrire
ou alors il faut vraiment que ça
répondre à de multiples critères pour
que ce soit transparent et que ce soit
comment
accepter
des deux parties il faut pas qu'il y ait
la moindre relation le moindre soupçon
de notion de consentement consentant
mais ça va au-delà du consentement il
faut que ce soit et je dirais presque il
faudrait que l'enseignant ne soit pas
l'enseignant direct moi je crois pas que
pour ça je pense qu'il y a une
commission très utile mais je crois pas
que pour ça cette commission soit très
utile dans notre société on pense tout
le temps quand il y a un problème c'est
un côté un pays hypocrite ça postériori
on met en place des régulations on va
réguler etc moi je trouve que ce qui est
formidable c'est le travail a fait
Élodie parce que maintenant le
bouddhisme n'est plus immunisé contre la
critique donc c'est maintenant où ça se
passera plus comme ça qui est l'UBF qui
est paub ou tout ce que vous voulez
c'est à dire que ce qui est important
c'est que jusque là on ne pouvait pas en
parler c'est la loi du silence c'est
vrai c'est on pouvait pas en parler
parce qu'il immédiatement on connecter
suspect de critiquer une religion qui a
priori était plus saine a priori n'était
pas comme les autres n'étaient pas comme
le catholicisme n'était pas comme ceci
comme cela maintenant c'est que ce n'est
pas une religion qui est une exception
et le seul fait que la parole soit
libérée qu'on puisse en parler c'est ça
la véritable contrainte qui pèse
aujourd'hui sur les centres à mon avis
et nous ce que l'on peut faire c'est
établir des recommandations mais après
chaque centre membre de l'UBF est libre
de faire ce qu'elle veut elle elle
dirige son centre comme bon lui semble
et on a absolument aucun droit de regard
sur leur fonctionnement on peut émettre
un avis si tenter que derrière il va
quoi que ce soit alors c'est quand même
un problème parce que même si je suis
ravie que que vous pensiez que le
la seule sortie du documentaire suffise
à mettre en garde je ne crois pas que ça
suffise du tout
la preuve en est que ce documentaire a
été diffusé une première fois en
septembre et que le livre a été publié
en septembre donc ça fait un peu plus de
huit mois et qui s'est rien passé et il
s'est rien passé à mon avis au nom de du
phénomène de la patate chaude que vous
évoquiez et du fait que chacun se
renvoie la responsabilité sur qui
pourrai-je justement émettre des
recommandations être un interlocuteur
privilégié pour des disciples qui
seraient désorientés et qui auraient
besoin d'informations fiables sur un
mètre bon personne ne prend en charge
cette responsabilité
l'Union bouddhiste de France qui
pourrait effectivement parce que quand
on tape bouddhisme on tombe sur vous en
l'état les centres de ce galerie potier
dont on parle dans le film sont toujours
référencés sur le site de L'union
bouddhiste de France et pas bah en fait
le problème c'est que les centres
riquent pas n'ont jamais pris leur
distance avec l'enseignement de ce
garream potier qui est toujours présenté
comme un maître éveillé que sur le site
de L'union bouddhiste de il faut qu'une
mention de notre enquête en fait il y a
rien qui est là pour dire voilà on a
pris connaissance effectivement de cette
libération de la parole de cette enquête
sur différents supports on n'est pas les
seuls à avoir travaillé là-dessus on a
des confrères qui travaillent là-dessus
en Hollande on a des confrères qui
travaillent là-dessus en Suisse en
Espagne il y a quand même quelques
journalistes qui essayent voilà de
porter cette parole publiquement mais ça
suffit pas il y a un moment où il va
falloir effectivement être beaucoup plus
clair sur ce qui est possible au nom ou
pas au nom de de l'accès à l'éveil et il
va falloir que les gens qui ont des
vraiment des problèmes dans les centres
sachent à qui s'adresser les centres
requins je suis désolé de vous
contredire mais le l'organisation rique
pas international
dès que la plainte a été déposée on a
aussitôt
retirer mis en retrait sauvegarder et on
lançait un audit et à la suite de quoi à
la suite de quoi des une charte
a été
mise à disposition de tous les membres
tous les centres ont obligation
évidemment de la suivre et tous les
membres peuvent s'y référer en cas de
problème donc on peut pas dire qu'ils
n'ont rien fait alors on peut dire
qu'ils ont pas fait grand-chose parce
que sur le sur le quand on quelqu'un qui
s'intéresse à qui va sur le site de
ricpa il y a une page entière consacrée
à ce gars une poésie où il fait passer
une demi mention de la gravité des
accusations dont il a fait l'objet il
est écrit que il a quitté la tête de
Ripa à la suite d'accusation d'anciens
disciples
donc qui compte aujourd'hui 117 cents
répartis dans 24 pays c'est un énorme
réseau ce gars une potche pour les naïfs
qui découvraient le bouddhisme c'était
l'auteur du livre tibétain de la vie et
de la mort qui est un best-seller de
littérature spirituelle il y a beaucoup
de gens qui considéraient que c'était le
numéro 2 du bouddhisme tibétain même si
évidemment ça veut pas dire grand chose
mais enfin c'était vraiment quelqu'un de
très important dans bouddhisme tibétain
son héritage
dalaï-lama par une lettre publique de je
sais pas une trentaine de pages
extrêmement difficiles à lire dans la
violence de ce qu'elle contient là le
dalaï-lama finit par dire ce gars une
Poitiers et disgracier donc on a beau
dire que par ailleurs que le dalaï-lama
n'a aucun rôle
hiérarchique puisqu'effectivement ce
n'est qu'une autorité morale
l'instant où il dit ce gars une coacher
et disgraphie ce gars une pochette
démissionne par vivant Thaïlande c'est
terminé donc en réalité il y a quand
même des gens dont la parole est
suffisamment importante et écouter et
cruciale pour que ça mette fin à la
carrière
des successeurs de du successeur de ce
galdre une pochette alors c'est ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure il y a encore
énormément de gens qui ne renie pas du
tout l'héritage de ce Garry coacher donc
en public il y a un vernis de oui on a
fait cette audit qui par ailleurs est
terrible pour Rick pas qui confirme tout
ce que disent les victimes et ensuite se
garer une coacher s'est retiré et partit
vivre en Thaïlande et ensuite les
héritiers de ce gars in potcher sont
toujours aux commandes de rickpa et ça
ça n'a pas changé du tout parce qu'il me
paraît important néanmoins je veux dire
au-delà de du rapport ce qu'il faut
faire comment le faire autorité
hiérarchique etc etc ce qui est vrai le
dalaï-lama à partir du moment où là il
Lama a émis sa vision sa vision des
choses immédiatement ça oui ça c'est
clair
justice a été que des signalements
en 94 il semble quelque chose qui est
important c'est quand on observe
l'évolution des des réseaux bouddhistes
et des forums ce qu'on a fait avec les
étudiants et en particulier les forums
liés à Ripa là il y a une vraie
libération de la parole il y a vraiment
une libération de la parole et pour moi
en tant que sociologue et c'est ça qui
est essentiel parce que ça veut dire que
il y a encore il y a encore quelques
années
cette parole elle était complètement
contrainte dans le dans le alors là pour
le coup moi j'étais contre plutôt contre
l'idée qu'on parle de système au sens de
systématique quoi de de du bouddhisme en
général par contre qui est qui est eu un
système recta alors là pour moi c'est
tout à fait clair là oui je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec ça il y avait il y
avait un système qui était verrouillé
par par sodium aujourd'hui ce système il
existe plus dans sa contrainte au niveau
des au niveau des des adeptes c'est à
dire on voit bien que les forums sur les
forums la parole est complètement
libérée si ça on avait été à l'époque de
de soyal ça aurait été juste impossible
ça sera le mot de la fin vraiment un
grand merci à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce débat doc merci
spécialement à vous pour avoir réalisé
cette cette enquête avec votre confrère
et puis encore merci à vous d'avoir
accepté notre invitation mais a pour
répondre face aux accusations qui
étaient portées à la suite de cette
enquête que nous avons diffusée dans
cette émission des Badoc vos réactions
ça sera
sur Twitter nous inviter je l'imagine se
font fort de réagir à ce que seront vos
réactions à la suite de cette émission
c'est le massali mérite un grand merci
parce qu'elle m'a aidé comme à la
coutumée à préparer cette émission je
vous donne tout simplement quant à moi
rendez-vous pour un prochain débat doc
et ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débat à très bientôt
[Musique]